it's official it looks like kate herron
is not coming back she is the loki
director for season one and i initially
thought this was gonna be bad news but
the person or persons who are replacing
her are coming from the moon night
series and i'm excited because the moon
knight series is just
incredible looking so far and i can't
wait for it to be released so i trust
that these directors who are being
trusted by marvel
to direct the next loki series which is
definitely one of their highest watch
series on disney plus so they definitely
put a lot of trust in these two guys who
are so far killing it if you ask me
these directors are normally coming from
the horror genre so i completely trust
them with something like moon knight
even doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness if you ask me because i know
that that movie is coming out with its
own sort of horror tone to it much more
darker
and i kind of like marvel's direction of
using horror directors to go into this
definite eerie dark side of marvel
cinematic universe if you know what i
mean i think that that is the situation
right now with the multiverse the
multiverse yet opens up a ton of
possibilities for new heroes but it also
opens up the possibilities of new
villains and the villains let me tell
you from the multiverse are definitely
going to be a lot scarier than we've
seen in the past in my opinion i feel
like this is only the beginning of what
the multiverse is going to show us
but let me know in the comments what you
guys think are you excited to see these
new directors take the helm for season 2
of loki uh it's definitely fun to sort
of switch around directors to give
different take on certain series uh this
is the first sequel for a series on
disney plus so i know that we have yet
to see i'm sure it's going to be bigger
and better but i mean we still have yet
to see how marvel handles a second
season of a series i again i do trust
them so anyways again comment down below
like this video if you did
subscribe if you can and i am doing this
every day so i'll see you tomorrow